Stephen is in Arizona is it hypocritical
to have visa in my mutual fund portfolio
it is one of my best performers well I
don't go through my investment portfolio
and figure out if there's if every
single company that is in there in every
mutual fund that I own is something I
agree with
I don't have time to do that I'm not
that legalistic about it
I don't buy single stocks and I wouldn't
buy single stocks and a company that did
something I disagree with but even then
you got to remember when you buy stock
in a company or when the mutual fund
that you own has bought stock in a
company the money does not go to the
company unless it's Treasury stock or an
initial public offering but those are
very very unusual transactions 99% of
the time that stock is bought from
someone else
and so if I [ __ ] if I put you know if I
have a share of a series of shares of
Home Depot and I want to sell them and
you buy them Home Depot doesn't get the
money I get the money I owned the shares
Home Depot doesn't benefit at all from
that transaction financially and so if
you hate Home Depot not buying Home
Depot stock from me does not it doesn't
compute it's like saying I hate
Chevrolet so I'm not gonna buy your
Chevrolet truck from you you know
because Chevrolet is not getting the
money that that's the point and so it's
not hypocritical in that sense because
visa is not profiting from the
transaction now what is happening is
when visa makes a profit off of
something you disagree with or I
disagree with and that profit would go
to enhance your pocketbook and so if a
company is doing something that makes a
profit off of something you disagree
with and yeah there's a touch of
hypocrisy that could be assigned to
there but again I don't you know here's
another example okay I've got a friend
whose dad was an alcoholic and he
strongly believes due to his childhood
and his particular religious beliefs
that to drink a beer is a really sinful
activity he really strongly believes
that now can he shop then at Kroger
where they sell beer would he be a
hypocrite can he shop at Publix where
they sell beer would he be a hypocrite
well I mean you can't you just can't
manage your life to that degree and
avoid that it's ridiculous you know
United Way largely is one of the largest
supporters of Planned Parenthood and I
am a pro-life guy so I don't give money
to United Way but my bank does virtually
every bank has a United Way program and
so I don't we don't donate the Ramsey
Foundation does not donate money the
United Way nor will we but I'm not gonna
stop doing business with a bank because
some of the profit they make off of me
they donate to something I don't agree
with you see the point
so you just every jot and tiddle you
cannot manage yourself to that level of
legalism and there so I think you're
okay and I the best I don't believe in
borrowing money but I do business with
banks that loan money
I don't borrow money from them but they
I mean I have accounts there and they
make money of as a result of me being
there and so I just don't have time to
deal with all these nuances of every
little thing and to avoid every possible
thing now the big ones the big stuff
that's right in front of you yeah you
need to avoid that like in my case I
tell people not to use credit cards
right I don't have credit cards I tell
people to cut up their credit cards I
won't let you do a debt free scream on
the air if you still use credit cards
it's one of the questions we ask you
because it's kind of stupid for me to
put you on the air and celebrate your
debt freedom when you're still using a
stupid credit card so it's inconsistent
we don't take credit cards on our online
store or in our live events sales or if
you walk in to Martha's place where our
nice coffee shop here the coffee's
free but if you want to buy one of our
nice books you're gonna pay for it with
a debit card or with cash or a check we
don't take credit cards but it would be
very hypocritical for me to say oh don't
use credit cards but use them to buy my
stuff you know so that's a little
different cuz that's like big right in
front of you deal but you know what what
does some company do four layers down
and in the company or you know and it's
one percent of the mutual fund that I
own in I own twenty eight different
mutual funds oh my lord I ain't got time
to keep up with all that and I got time
to scrub every one of them for their
sins no I don't think you're
hypocritical at all in that case hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or twenty seven thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in economy
you